in the middle of a global pandemic
a ragtag group of welders heavy machine
operators and builders were brought
together
[Music]
they were given plans for a mysterious
structure
[Music]
with little information on what exactly
they were building their only clue was
scrawled across the top of their plants
spin launch a space catapult
in this exclusive behind-the-scenes
documentary i talk to the people behind
this new innovative company
[Music]
spin launch is attempting to subvert a
problem that plagues the space industry
the rocket equation
the rocket equation has been the tyrant
engineers have feuded with from the dawn
of the space age
a simple equation that describes how
much fuel a rocket needs to carry a
payload to its destination
the tyranny of this equation is that the
fuel needed to deliver that payload is a
payload itself a compounding problem
that makes rockets more fuel than rocket
typical rockets are more than 90 fuel
spin launch is trying to change that
paradigm by imparting as much velocity
as possible to the payload on the ground
eliminating as much fuel as possible
from the rocket's weight while greatly
reducing the size and complexity of the
non-reusable components
their plan to spin a small rocket in a
centrifugal mass accelerator under a
vacuum up to an astonishing speed before
releasing it punching through the
thickest layers of our atmosphere at
hypersonic speeds gaining 72 kilometers
of altitude of nothing but pure kinetic
energy before splitting its fairings and
unveiling a substantially miniaturized
two-stage rocket to continue its journey
into orbit
you may question the numbers here but
this isn't the first time this has been
done
project harp standing for high altitude
research project managed to get a
projectile to 180 kilometers of altitude
with a high-powered gun
they achieved a muzzle velocity nearly
identical to spin launch's planned
launch velocity however scaling a
kinetic energy launch system up to
launch a 10 ton projectile needs spin
launches technology
of course all of this is easier said
than done
the challenge facing spin launch's
engineers is immense
this endeavor demands several new key
enabling technologies
so in terms of key enabling technologies
carbon fiber certainly takes center
stage
that's david wren spin launch is vp of
technology i spoke with him on the spin
launch factory floor about the carbon
fiber reinforced plastic that they are
using for their tether you know in terms
of its strength to weight ratio it's
it's essentially unmatched by any other
material on earth and the amazing thing
is that it's actually
available in industrial quantities now
and the engineering tools and
simulation methods exist to really
quickly iterate and understand what a
composite structure will do and then we
have structures and test rigs like this
to validate uh in the real world that
the components actually fail at the
expected loads so just to give you a
sense of the strength of carbon fiber
this is a pultrusion so this is made by
taking
carbon fiber toe essentially spools of
carbon fiber and pulling it through a
heated dye
with a resin bath basically the resin
gets impregnated into the the carbon
fiber toe as it gets pulled through the
heated dye and you get these really nice
highly uni-directional
you know structures that can be used for
uh you know spin launch right and so as
as as small as this cross section is
right i think this is about an eighth of
an inch uh thick and only a few inches
wide this can do just under a quarter
million pounds of of total load capacity
uh which is which is really really
impressive i'm trying to convert it to
metric in my head it's like oh yeah no
that's a lot
yeah i think that's like a million
newtons or something like that so
and then if you look at you know this is
where it gets interesting is is you know
can you build really you know thick
cross sections of of carbon fiber you
can see there's there's really great um
is this protruded as well so this is not
pultruded this is laid up and then it's
it's cured in an autoclave okay so this
is essentially a subsection
of the laminate that you would see at
the root of the tether on the suborbital
system
so this is this is like this is not
unidirectional or protruded but if it
were if you were to take this this same
cross section here and and and basically
make this a protruded uh you know fiber
if you just stack up multiple protruded
sections you would get about you know
nine million pounds of total load
capacity uh through this cross section
so it's it's impressively strong for
what it is i mean it's it's heavier than
you'd expect like holding holding a
carbon fiber brick
i don't think there's i've never seen an
application where that much carbon fiber
has been laid up it's it's rare to see
carbon fiber this thick yeah it really
is rare the final fully scaled tether
for spin launch's orbital system is
likely going to be the single strongest
tensile structure on earth let's do the
math on that
spin launch aims to yeast its aeroshell
containing the miniaturized rocket
system at about mach 6
that's roughly 2 kilometers per second
with a radius of 45 meters the tether
will need to spin 450 times per minute
to attain that velocity at that rate the
g-loading on the tether will be 10 000
g's
meaning this aeroshell is going to exert
a force 10 000 times greater than its
weight due to gravity the aeroshell with
the payload and rocket is going to weigh
approximately 10 metric tons so that
means the tether at the tip is going to
need to be able to support 100 000
metric tons or 100 million kilograms
to put that in context a fully loaded
falcon 9 weighs about 0.55
million kilograms
so this tether is going to need to
support the equivalent weight of
182 falcon 9.
this is going to require a hefty piece
of carbon composite with a
cross-sectional area of at least
0.23 meters squared
that explains the brick of carbon fiber
we saw that brick could support 4.1
million kilograms
so the full-scale tether will need to be
24.4 times this size at its tip
but that's just the tip this equation
tells us why carbon fiber is so vital to
this endeavor because each section of
the tether has to support the section
above it its strength to weight ratio
needs to be exceptional
if we calculate the tether area near the
hub for the same carbon composite the
tether only needs to increase an area by
2.5 times at about 0.56 meters squared
we would of course need to add a safety
factor of at least 1.5 increasing these
dimensions by 50 percent
i have skimmed over this equation here
but if you want to learn more about the
engineering of this system and energy of
getting to space in general i've created
an entire course on brilliant to partner
this video and you can sign up for it
with the link in the description
that design is perfectly feasible and is
reflected in spin launch's renders we
even have the manufacturing skills
necessary to build even larger composite
structures thanks to the wind industry
so this is all well and good but
spinning a carbon fiber composite up to
mach 6 isn't possible in air the
aerodynamic heating would destroy it
so to solve this issue spin launch
created a massive vacuum chamber around
its tether
you know there's a bunch of
things at the beginning of spin launch
that were non-starters for a lot of
people like even just building the large
diameter vacuum chamber
uh you know people were telling us you
know the one behind me here would cost
you know tens of millions of dollars to
build and we ended up doing it you know
we had this really really kind of
scrappy lean mindset and we ended up
doing it for you know less than a couple
million dollars with you know about 10
people right which is unheard of
there's some large industrial vacuum
chambers out there but but but there's
you know quite a few of the really large
chambers that are in the world are for
aerospace applications
and so they're achieving
uh extremely high levels of not only
vacuum but cleanliness right and so the
cost is is proportional to that and it's
kind of exponential you know they're
achieving vacuums that are on the order
of uh ten to the negative eight millibar
tour you know typically we're operating
at about a million times you know worse
than that spin launch is breaking new
ground with this kind of vacuum chamber
typical large volume vacuum chambers
like the world's largest one at space
power facility in sandusky ohio are
designed to simulate the vacuum of space
those require an extremely low pressure
vacuum with tight tolerances and control
of contamination
they even need specialized tools like
lamps to simulate the radiation and heat
emanating from the sun and cryogenic
cooling to simulate the heat of space
the people that built these facilities
are the industrial experts spin launch
had to draw from and most thought they
would never be able to build a vacuum
chamber this large on their budget
but spin launch does have some things on
their side
they didn't need that extreme of a
vacuum as their goal is not to simulate
the vacuum of space
their goal is to minimize drag and the
power required to overcome it minimize
the aerodynamic heating that would
destroy the tether and eliminate all
those pesky aerodynamic effects like
flutter
that means spinlodge could use cheaper
materials like mild steel where ultra
high vacuum chambers need more expensive
specialized processed materials to avoid
outgassing where gases within the metal
in the form of oxides or simply
dissolved within the metal are released
into the vacuum
it also makes the process of drawing a
vacuum much easier drawing a vacuum
isn't as simple as just turning on a
pump and leaving it on long enough the
more air you draw out the harder it
becomes as you are not only working
against a continually growing pressure
gradient but statistical probability
the first stage of drawing a vacuum is
to remove the bulk gas at this stage the
gas is a viscous fluid and the molecules
within the chamber interact with each
other often
here we can use traditional fluid flow
pumps like a positive displacement pump
that mechanically move molecules out of
the chamber and higher pressure air at
the back of the chamber forces more air
to fill the space created allowing more
air to be pumped out but as gas is
removed from the chamber the distance
between the molecules increases this is
called the mean free path the distance a
molecule can travel without colliding
with another molecule
now pressure is really just molecules
colliding and as collisions become more
infrequent the pressure gradients that
are needed to achieve equilibrium begin
to vanish
meaning it takes longer and longer for
equilibrium to be established and the
rate the pump can remove molecules
lowers as there are simply fewer and
fewer molecules near the pump to remove
at some point viscous flow stops
entirely and we enter a flow regime
called molecular flow where the distance
between collisions is actually larger
than the internal dimensions of the
vacuum chamber meaning the molecules are
statistically more likely to just bounce
around inside the chamber with nothing
forcing them towards the exit
at this stage it is impossible to
actively pump the molecules out
the molecular pumps needed for this flow
regime instead act like some kind of
venous fly trap waiting for a molecule
to enter it and then its job is to
prevent the molecule from returning to
the original chamber
turbomolecular pumps are basically
multiple levels of turbines that knock
molecules in one direction and prevent
them from traveling backwards
these pumps require insane rotation
speeds anywhere from 36 000 rpm to 72
000 rpm and need incredibly tight
tolerances too
they are trying to pump individual
molecules after all
so it goes without saying these kinds of
pumps are expensive
all the while outgassing and other leaks
are actively working against a game of
pure chance creating a high vacuum
requires extreme precision in
manufacturing and design spin launch
didn't need any of this
mark sipperly the director of
engineering at spinlaunch walked me
through the vacuum pump station at the
new mexico site
here in the vacuum plant the
the most familiar thing would be the
tube that came out of the chamber and
then runs underground is this manifold
so this is the very end of it so off of
this vacuum manifold we then have a
series of three different types of pumps
up on top we first have roughing pumps
which pull the atmosphere from like one
atmosphere down to about um 30 millibar
those are dry screw prompts they're
essentially like overlapping uh lobes
it's one form of like a turbo charger
then the next stage is we have this
roots pump which is like a another shape
of a turbocharger is the rotating twin
screw pumps all right so that kicks on
at about 30 millibar right so it's
mostly only effective 30 millibar and
below
but you'll notice that each pump
it exhausts into
a pump that's a slightly higher pressure
all right so this roots pump only works
at 30 millibar and below but it can't
exhaust that all the way out to one
atmosphere so that's backed by another
pistons pump and then once we get down
below one millibar then we're gonna turn
on these vapor diffusion pumps which
only are really effective down at the
very low pressure and those work like
oil jets so you vaporize oil you shoot
it down a series of channels and it
grabs on to the air molecules runs them
down a series of tubes and then you have
these cooling loops that will then
condense out the oil and then the water
or sorry the air progressively makes its
way through
like a long path and then eventually
gets to a roots pump which can grab onto
it and then that goes to a piston pump
and then all the way out
so we talked before you know vacuum may
not be the best description because most
people think of vacuums like a hard
vacuum like you know in tor is what most
people are used to like e to the minus
seven torso like six zeros and then the
number um
that that's like true vacuum that's hard
vacuum that's where you test like you
know like electrical propulsion systems
and like high-end space features
that is nowhere near the atmosphere that
we need and that's that vacuum is also
really expensive to get to and you have
to follow a lot of stringent rules like
you can't use steels you have to use
aluminum or like thin coatings um you
know even like putting your fingerprint
in a vacuum that low would take like
weeks to boil off we only require the
equivalent of like to the minus three
torr all right so 0.01 millibar or 0.1
millibar today we're going to be running
it like one millibar because we don't we
only pull the vacuum that we need
because vacuum is expensive it's closer
to described as like a high atmospheric
chamber than a vacuum chamber
specifically this is another one of
those technical issues that the internet
made a big deal out of without fully
understanding what spin launch actually
needed out of the vacuum chamber
one of the other primary concerns
expressed on the internet was the tricky
and unique problem of a vehicle
traveling at hypersonic speeds from a
vacuum into a thick sea level atmosphere
to begin with we need to prevent air
from rushing into the vacuum chamber
once the vehicle is released spin launch
is aiming to be a high frequency launch
system capable of launching multiple
satellites per day holding the vacuum
between launches to decrease energy and
time costs however the primary concern
is the disastrous effects that air would
have as it meets the tether spinning at
hypersonic speeds
this would be an incredibly expensive
single shot system if this was allowed
to happen
to solve this problem spin launch needed
a way of sealing the chamber extremely
quickly after launch
so inside this long tube attached to the
vacuum chamber is a double door airlock
with doors on either end of the tube
this tube is also under vacuum during
spin up as the vehicle is released using
a release mechanism that spin launch
kept hidden from our cameras throughout
the shoes it passes into the exit tunnel
where the first door rapidly closes
behind it
as this first door is closing the second
door will begin to open the atmosphere
will begin rushing into the tube and
give the aeroshell its first taste of
the hypersonic flight regime it will be
flying in
the first and second door need to close
quickly enough to prevent air from
entering the vacuum chamber this is not
an easy problem
millisecond delays that may seem trivial
in most cases start to mount up when the
vehicle travels this quickly
the time it takes for an electrical
signal to propagate the time it takes to
overcome the inertia of the door the
time it takes for a proper seal to form
all these problems become matters of
survival at these speeds
once again spinlons are keeping their
cards close to their chests on this one
but they did give me a demonstration of
the door closing in their factory an
engineering hub in long beach california
well it's moving really fast and so when
the when the
you know
without specifying this you can do a
countdown yep so whenever you're ready
for a countdown
yeah so basically what's going to happen
is
you know this is going to be filled with
a you know for lack of a better word
like a a black door
which basically you'll see that like you
can pass through this with a vehicle and
then in an instant it's going to be
closed okay so and again it's like
faster on the blink of an eye so you'll
see a little bit of settling as it as
after it closes um but it's you know
basically 95 closed within you know 30
milliseconds oh wow okay
closing airlock and five
four
three
two
one
it's pretty fast yeah that's not what i
was expecting
yeah it's fast so it actually closes
like it's actually hinged there's a
pivot yeah okay yeah i wasn't sure if it
was gonna be a sliding thing but the
hinged one makes sense as well
yeah that wasn't what i was expecting so
it's 100 reusable basically you can set
that back up again and do it again and
again and again so that's a key aspect
of it is that you don't have you know
any major consumables in the process
so that's cool it's fast
visceral
all right
it's a door closing i don't know what
that's good
it's really important not to let air
back in so yeah yeah that's why it
happened
[Laughter]
so the you know the airlock is a really
critical subsystem of the overall effect
you know of the overall architecture as
you travel from vacuum into the
atmosphere because the tether is still
rotating at high velocities you want to
maintain the vacuum inside of the vacuum
chamber and so the air lock is your
first line of defense for that and so we
have multiple redundant air locks just
like what you see here that the vehicle
passes through and it subsequently
closes behind the vehicle you know
preventing the air from in rushing and
re-entering into the vacuum chamber so
the exit tunnel is really the only
portion of the chamber that experiences
a rise in pressure i imagine that allows
you to reset and like increase frequency
of launches as well if you're not having
to read like
yeah totally so so you can you can do um
you know you can essentially provide a
you know
an air locked space for the end of the
tether as well and so you can basically
just repressurize that space as you load
in new vehicles it's possible you could
do vehicle integration in vacuum but
currently we're anticipating actually
re-pressuring a small portion of you
know interfacing around the tether
repression repressurizing a small
portion and integrating the vehicle
without it being in vacuum
how many launches a day do you think you
can manage i think that's like one of
the advantages of this that you can yeah
i i think on the very high end it's
upwards of ten i think on the low end
it's it's it's about you know five is a
is a pretty good nominal target for us
we see viability there
in spin launch's public videos the
secondary airlock has simply been sheets
of moiler
this is one of the few problems that
becomes easier as the launcher scales
as the exit tunnel grows in length it
will take air longer to reach the door
at the base of the exit tunnel
spin launch have only just begun these
one 3 scale tests
with their fastest launched date at 1.6
mach slowly ramping up the speed of
launch as they test their systems
this prototype launcher features some
other simplifications compared to their
final planned configuration
one of the most obvious problems to
tackle is the issue of vibration when a
spinning object's weight is not evenly
distributed it will vibrate
this is how rumble feedback works in
gaming controllers a simple electric
motor with an uneven weight attached
however with the structure as large as
spin launches tether spinning several
times per second any imbalance could
shake the entire structure to the ground
this is a major problem because by
design the tether releases a 10 ton
weight right at its maximum velocity
spin launch needs a way to balance the
tether after launch
there is a very simple solution to this
problem though release a balanced weight
from the other side of the arm at the
same time right now they are simply
releasing a counterweight that slams
into an armored section of the vacuum
chamber
we saw one of these counterweights being
manufactured out of fiberglass in the
long beach factory
however over the long term having to
clean up the mess this creates after
each and every launch is far from ideal
the ideal solution would be to release a
counterweight in the form of another
launch vehicle after a single half
rotation of the tether
the oil filled journal bearing the
massive axle sits upon should be able to
absorb the force of this imbalance over
a period of time this short
the next issue we need to concern
ourselves with is the aeroshell punching
into the atmosphere at mach 6. this
again is a fairly unique problem
typically weight is a restraining factor
in aerospace
but for spin launch the energy required
to spin the aeroshell up to speed is
actually rather trivial it's on the
order i mean i like to use the analogy
of like a tesla right so the tesla model
s plaid is about 0.7 megawatts so on the
low end it's about 100 teslas
um
but it really comes down for the full
scale yeah for the full scale yeah yeah
for the orbital system you're talking
about like on the low end on the very
low end you know it's it's probably
about 65 to 70 megawatts and again that
really depends on where you end up with
the final orbital tether you know
whether or not you you know what what
safety factor you operate with what what
you know uh you know what tether
strength you end up with your effective
you know tether you know cross-sectional
strength
that all feeds back into itself and then
and then you have to you know kind of
scale it accordingly i would say like
really conservatively like
you know if you wanted to spin up really
fast then you're talking about a higher
power demand so whether you want to spin
up in an hour two hours you know
proportionately makes a difference of of
how much power that you need um
so but you know on the high end you're
talking about maybe 150 megawatts of
power which is like
i don't know maybe in layman terms it
sounds significant but you know you can
you know there's you know there's motor
catalogs where you purchase you know the
motor that that has that capacity right
and so this is you know it's industrial
scale uh hardware and certainly uh
yeah
mostly off the shelf do you need to
worry about like grid integration at all
when you're when you're suddenly
drawing that much power no i mean uh for
better for worse no because you're
typically you know particularly for for
early uh you know orbital accelerators
that we're building we're expecting them
to be in in really remote locations
um kind of remote coastal locations
green field sites that don't have um
substantial
existing on-site you know resources or
power
so you're you're basically you know
bringing your own power you know and so
you have to you know decide on you know
what what is your energy source are you
doing energy recapture you know et
cetera spin launch claims their total
energy demand per spin-up is about 100
megawatt hours the cost per kilowatt
hour for industrial facilities is about
six cent so that's a cost of six
thousand dollars in electricity cost
that's insanely cheap to put that into
perspective 100 megawatt hours is
equivalent to about 9 600 liters of
kerosene about 8 tons of fuel
for reference the electron rocket from
new zealand's small satellite launching
company rocket lab capable of launching
a similar sized satellite weighs a total
of 12.5 tons
the vast majority of that weight being
its own fuel and oxidizer spin launch
claims their rockets will need to carry
about 30 percent of the fuel and
oxidizer compared to their competitors
they are essentially replacing the first
stage of a traditional rocket with an
easily reusable kinetic launch system
spin launch will also be able to
recapture a good deal of the electricity
stored as kinetic energy in the tether
using regenerative braking
even further reducing their electricity
bill
because of all this the limiting factor
for spin launch in terms of weight is
actually the weight the tether can
support and as a result it actually
makes sense to maximize the density of
the aeroshell
because it affects a variable that will
drastically improve its ability to punch
through the atmosphere its ballistic
coefficient
ballistic coefficient is essentially an
object's ability to resist air
resistance think about how hard it is to
throw a feather no matter how hard you
throw it it's not going to go very far
it's got a large surface area for air
resistance to act upon relative to its
weight
that's a low ballistic coefficient
ballistic coefficient is found by
dividing the mass of the projectile by
the drag coefficient multiplied by the
cross-sectional area
so spin launch effectively wants to
maximize the mass relative to the
cross-sectional area this is obviously
not typical for aerospace vehicles
yeah if you look at re-entry capsules uh
whether it's for something like the
stardust return capsule where it's
really really high velocity or you look
at re-entry from orbit for a manned
capsule or something like the space
shuttle they're typically using thermal
protection systems that are extremely
low density like on the order of you
know less than 300 kilograms per cubic
meter just basically foam
and so so
typically that means you're making like
significant compromises like the
material often is you know brittle or
prone to fracture
um you know or or really expensive or
gets worn away and then you have to
replace you know the tiles kind of in
the infamous case of the space shuttle
so what we're dealing with is you know
you're on the tip of the vehicle you
have um you know materials like copper
which you know not only are they you
know a significantly higher density
right you're talking about you know
thousands of kilograms per per cubic
meter but they also have really great
thermal conductivity so you can
basically as you transition through the
atmosphere you have a high you know heat
load but then you're you know dumping
that basically into heavy dense
materials that have good thermal
conductivity this is one of those
unintuitive consequences of this style
of launch when i first saw the
full-scale aeroshell on the spin launch
factory floor i first asked if i could
ride it like a cowboy but then
immediately noticed the bi-metallic nose
cone i knew from looking at it that it
was made from copper and aluminium that
struck me as extremely odd those metals
would melt at the temperatures i
associate with hypersonic speeds but
because spin launch launches at mach 6
it actually transitions through the
lower atmosphere rather quickly and as a
result the heat generated can simply be
absorbed by these large heat sinks
aluminium and copper's high thermal
conductivity means the heat is
distributed through the body of the
aeroshell before it has a chance to
damage the vehicle the hefty carbon
fiber shell is also incredibly strong
spinlodge has already pulled their
smaller scale aeroshells out of the
ground buried several feet deep from the
force of impact and reused them with
minimal refurbishment
with a parachute these aeroshells will
be fully reusable with minimal
maintenance especially as they serve no
function other than to protect the inner
rocket stages
this isn't an intricate mechanical
machine
launching from the ground at these
speeds comes with advantages too if we
plot drag coefficient versus mach number
for a bullet-like projectile something
rather unintuitive occurs the drag
coefficient rises as you would expect
until we hit mach 1 at this point it
starts to fall as mach numbers increase
this is the equation for drag it's
proportional to drag coefficient air
density and velocity squared with drag
coefficient being lower at hypersonic
speeds it actually makes some sense to
punch through the thick lower atmosphere
where the high density air causes drag
to rise as fast as possible deceleration
is a function of time after all meters
per second squared meters per second
lost per second let's calculate the
dynamic pressure this drag would create
at launch and the deceleration it would
cause
the dynamic pressure is found by
multiplying air density by the velocity
squared and dividing by two at sea level
at mach 6 the dynamic pressure will be
about 2.6 megapascals the final
aeroshell is one meter in diameter and
has a drag coefficient of about 0.1
which means the force applied to the
aeroshell at launch will be 205
kilonewtons
this sounds like a lot but here's where
ballistic coefficient comes in the drag
force is being applied to a 10 ton body
moving at mach 6
that's a lot of inertia
force equals mass by acceleration
acceleration equals force divided by
mass that means high mass equals less
deceleration in this case deceleration
due to drag will be about 19.8 meters
per second per second at launch but it
will rapidly decrease as we move through
to thinner and thinner layers of the
atmosphere and lose velocity in fact
with spin launch's planned trajectory we
can plot the atmospheric density the
aeroshell will encounter over time
halving in just five seconds and
dropping to less than 10
of the original air density in 15
seconds
while gravity will remain more or less
constant at 9.8 meters per second per
second
that means gravity losses form the
majority of energy losses in our
transition to orbit in total spin launch
will lose about 150 meters per second of
velocity to drag and 1000 meters per
second to gravity
satellites like starlink orbit at 500
kilometers with a velocity of about 7
700 meters per second
so even if spin launch maintained their
250 meter per second velocity from
launch up until the aeroshell broke
apart the two-stage rocket motor hidden
within would still have its work cut out
first
however now free from the mass of the
aeroshell the substantially miniaturized
rocket needs only a fraction of the mass
of fuel and oxidizer to rapidly
accelerate the 200 kilogram satellite
the largest satellite the system can
launch through the thin atmosphere at
this altitude we can actually graph the
relative velocity of the spacecraft over
time starting at mach 6 at launch and
ending up at 1 500 meters per second
when the aeroshell splits apart
the rocket motors then kick in to
rapidly accelerate the satellite to its
7
700 meter per second orbital velocity
the physics here absolutely check out
but whether the economics and cost of
development will be viable is the big
question to be answered
spin launch has built a one-third scale
prototype at a relatively low cost but
the hardest part of this technology is
scale they have reached 1.6 mach thus
far have tested their satellite
components at 10 000 g in their test
facility in long beach and are
continually upping their test parameters
pushing further and further
this is a comparison of spacex and spin
launch's proposed launch trajectory but
it doesn't tell the full story of the
real driving issue here economics
a spacex launch to low earth orbit costs
about 67 million dollars the heaviest
falcon 9 payload to date has been 16
250 kilograms on a densely packed
stairlink machine that equates to a
launch price of about four thousand one
hundred dollars per kilogram however
small satellite launch companies like
rocket lab who offer greater control
over orbit
and launch schedules charge about
fifteen thousand to twenty five thousand
dollars per kilogram
dollars per kilogram is not a perfect
metric but gives us some idea of the
competition spin launch is facing
spin launch's main competitive advantage
is in the decrease of expandable
materials like fuel while substantially
miniaturizing rocket components
they also have huge potential to launch
far more frequently than their
competitors helping the economics of
scale to kick in
spin launch claims to be targeting an
ambitious per launch price in the range
of half a million dollars placing them
at two thousand five hundred dollars per
kilogram
in my time in spin launch talking to
their engineers it's clear they are
excited and believe in this company
the basic napkin physics of spin launch
absolutely check out and they are well
on their way of solving the engineering
challenges but scaling up this monstrous
engineering effort is going to require
enormous amounts of investment and spin
launch could not disclose the answer to
many of my questions as they seek
patents for their solutions
i got little info on one of the most
difficult parts of the launch system the
release mechanism for the aeroshell even
the 3d model spin launch provided for
this video had the release mechanism
removed so we had to model our own along
with the internal rocket structure
the design of the satellites is another
problem due to the mass of g's the
satellites have to survive but
g-hardening isn't as large an
engineering challenge as the internet
seems to think
the most difficult part so besides the
structures is also the reaction wheel
so the reaction wheel is generates
momentum and basically steals the bus
and so it typically is a big mass that's
canter levered up at a certain angle so
which is the one thing that we don't
like you don't want having a big mass
sticking up on a can of relief this is
what i assumed was going to be like a
difficult thing to because it inherently
has to be fairly high mass to control
the satellite right and so we've done a
lot of work to instead of re-engineering
the wheel itself and figuring out
different ways to do that we basically
just took and created took a clever way
of deploying the wheel so we support the
wheel in the flat orientation
and we so when it's spinning it's well
supported the bearings are unloaded and
so it can spin and do its thing and then
we deploy the wheel
for when it actually needs to operate
so it's a it's a simple solution for
what could have been a really difficult
problem and does the
the axis of the actual wheel cause any
issues when it's like being g-loaded i
imagine that it's like a fairly high
weight to have on an axle yeah so we we
what we do is we unload the bearings and
as part of the deployment methods we
actually move we reload the wheel into
the bearings oh okay so it's just taken
off completely
again trying to make simple solutions
for very difficult problems yeah
and like that
like those are very simple answers to
like like i figured that the like the
inertial wheels would be difficult
there's like then you just think about
it like oh yeah that's actually a fairly
easy thing to just not deal with you
don't have to have it in the exact
configuration when you like launch and
the same with the solar panels you can
have them i guess you said loaded yeah
so it's the the problems aren't
necessarily hard to deal with
it's just you have to think differently
and so it's not that these are difficult
problems we just have to change the way
we think about designing satellites a
little bit it's not a lot the the nice
part is too that over the last 60 years
what people been trying to do with
satellites actually has helped us
because they want to reduce mass they
want to make things stronger so
every bit that they forcing them to deal
with shock and vibe already helps us and
it already inherently starts to make
them more g hardened most components we
don't have to do anything to them
maybe a little epoxy here
but like we one of the most surprising
events that we have here amongst the
entire team is we took a board that had
a capacitor stuck up you know maybe a
quarter of an inch and we all looked at
like okay that thing's just gonna fly
off and hit the wall and we spun it and
we brought it back and it just went
and that was it and we all like all
right our intuition is completely
changing and and it's because it's it's
so little mass and it's being held on by
two pieces of steel
you know the amount of force that that
was really importing on those two pieces
of steel was relatively small
so it just bent over and we all kind of
like oh yeah after you think about it it
does make sense so okay yeah just
survive so our intuition is starting to
grow about yeah this little connector
that's sticking up really isn't that big
of a deal and so that has been
uh in a positive way very surprising so
which is great
g's can only create forests where there
is mass and it turns out the satellite
industry has been finding ways to reduce
mass for decades a simple aluminium can
is capable of withstanding 10 000 g's
with a basic redesign of its structure
minimizing weight located on unsupported
surfaces lowers the mass available to be
multiplied by the g's and some simple
corrugation can help the aluminium
absorb some of the loading without
buckling we spun up an off-the-shelf
stair tracking camera using spin
launch's in-house centrifugal
accelerator which can already achieve 10
000 g's and the camera worked perfectly
fine just moments later
this is a really interesting engineering
challenge that i think the internet is
giving a hard time for some bizarre
reason posing questions about basic
physics calculations without actually
doing the math and then saying it's
impossible even missing the fact that
kinetic energy launch systems have
already reached beyond the karman line
six decades ago if you want to check the
math and physics of this problem
yourself instead of taking my word for
it i have in partnership with brilliant
created an entire course deep diving
into this problem
starting with an in-depth interactive
lesson on the physics of orbit and
traditional rocket launches and moving
on through to interactive calculations
of the launch speeds a kinetic launch
system like this would need to achieve
and the design considerations for the
tether itself
this is your chance to test your
understanding of the things you learned
in this video with a curated interactive
course
all designed with fun interactive real
engineering blueprints
you can get access to that course right
now and all of brilliant other curated
interactive courses by clicking the link
in the description
you can get started for free but the
first 500 people to do so will get 20
off brilliant annual premium
subscription with that you can level up
your stem skills no matter your
experience or develop your scientific
thinking with courses on computer
science fundamentals statistics and
algorithm fundamentals you can kickstart
a career in coding with their curated
courses
brilliant has been the longest running
partnership on this channel starting in
2017 they have funded nearly 40 of the
videos on this channel this is a major
milestone in both of our journeys
creating in-depth lessons together to
test and deepen the knowledge you learn
in our videos
a natural partnership where we can help
each other fulfill our mission of
inspiring and educating the next
generation of scientists and engineers
if you're looking for something else to
watch right now you could watch our last
video on the life limiting challenges
facing the next generation of spacesuits
or you could watch real science's new
video on the strange phenomenon of deep
sea gigantism